- On ne remarque plus
l'architecture grandiose
l l la gare de train de Lviv.
Elle est noyée par un raz-
de-marée de passagers.
Destination : l'exil, la paix.
Tous en mode survie, à peine
capables de penser à l'instant
présent, ils ont les traits
tirés, le visage trempé par
les larmes, le regard absent.
Il faut encore se frayer
un chemin, patienter souvent
plus de 20 heures, pour monter à
bord des trains vers la Pologne.
Pour certains, c'est déjà trop.
Demain? Ils n'ont pas la force
ou l'envie d'y penser.
"J'ai du mal à expliquer
ce que jenenenens, dit Ruslana.
Je me sens trahie par cet autre
pays. Les enfants n'ont rien
fait pour mériter ce qui
se passe. C'est juste cruel.
C'est ce que je crois. C'est
de la cruauté, de la trahison."
Elle et ses filles,
Mélanie et Paris, reviendront.
Ruslana refuse de monter
à bord pour un aller-simple.
Svetlana, son mari et leur fils
espéraient aussi prendre
un train pour la Pologne
mais on leur bloque le passage.
S'ils insistent pour partir
tous les trois, ils n'iront
nulle part.
"Ils m'ont dit que je devais
défendre mon pays, dit Serguï,
mais comment, si je n'ai jamais
tenu une arme dans mes mains?
Je n'ai pas fait mon service
militaire. À la frontière de
la Pologne, on nous attend
pour nous conduire en Espagne."
(pleurs)
Svetlana est anéantie.
Il y a ceux qui partent,
mais il y a aussi ceux
qui arrivent : 10 000, 20 000,
30 000 personnes passent ici
tous les jours. Ce qui était,
il y a une semaine à peine,
une place publique relativement
déserte s'est transformée
en véritable village
de la solidarité.
Un repas chaud, un thé,
une sucrerie : c'est le moins
que pouvaient faire ces femmes.
Elles ont des amis, des parents
coincés dans les zones
de combat. Accueillir ceux
qui ont pu fuir leur apporte
un peu de réconfort. Nathalia
a acheté des provisions
pour les faire cuisiner
par un ami restaurateur.
"Pour moi, c'est dur
de les voir forcés de quitter
leur maison. Je suis chez moi,
ici, et je peux faire quelque
chose pour aider. D'autres
ne peuvent pas, parce qu'ils
arrivent, ils ont très peur.
Ils ont fait la route pendant
30 heures, en se tenant debout,
les enfants allongés à trois,
quatre sur un siège.
Moi et tout le monde, on vient
aider comme on peut."
"C'est ce qu'ils peuvent
contribuer à l'effort de guerre.
Ça va aussi conduire
à la victoire", dit Volodymyr.
"L'amour, c'est notre arme
la plus puissante, dit-il,
et avec les peuples européens
et tous les gens dans le monde
qui croient en l'Ukraine,
nous allons gagner."
(explosion)
Ailleurs au pays, c'est tout
sauf de l'amour qui sert d'arme.
La caméra de cette voiture
a capturé une explosion
dans la ville de Tchernihiv.
Elle est survenue dans
un quartier résidentiel, près
d'une école et d'un hôpital,
selon les secouristes sur place.
Plus tôt dans la journée,
c'est un réservoir d'huile
qui était en flammes. Le bilan
est lourd : au moins 33 morts,
selon les autorités.
Volodymyr Zelinsky continue
d'appeler l'OTAN à imposer
une zone d'exclusion dans tout
l'espace aérien de l'Ukraine,
en vain.
"Si nous n'existons plus,
alors, Dieu nous en préserve,
la Lettonie, la Lituanie,
l'Estonie seront les prochaines,
dit-il, puis la Moldavie,
la Géorgie, la Pologne, et ils
iront jusqu'au mur de Berlin,
croyez-moi. Le monde doit
montrer sa force sans se battre,
sans perdre des gens, car
la force, c'est la diplomatie."
En soirée, une lueur d'espoir :
les Russes et les Ukrainiens
annonçaient s'être entendus
pour un cessez-le-feu partiel
pour permettre des corridors
d'évacuation de la population
civile et l'acheminement d'aide
humanitaire.
Il serait grand temps pour
Kharkiv, qui brûle toujours.
Depuis trois jours, la cité
d'un million et demi
d'Ukrainiens subit l'acharnement
des missiles et des obus
de la Russie. Le centre-ville
n'est plus que débris.
On cherche et on compte
les morts. Maria fait
ce qu'elle peut pour documenter
ce qu'elle décrit comme
les crimes de la Russie.
"Je suis épuisée, dit-elle.
Le stress est constant,
et quand je peux enfin dormir,
mes seules pensées, mon rêve,
c'est que ce n'est pas en train
de se produire ici, à Kharkiv.
Je vais me réveiller dans une
ville comme il y a une semaine,
qui n'a pas été bombardée,
où la guerre n'a pas commencé."
Mais c'est un cauchemar éveillé
que vivent les résidents ici,
un cauchemar que Mohanad a mis
presque trois jours à fuir.
L'étudiant libanais était à
deux mois de compléter
ses études de médecine.
Un rêve anéanti.
"Tout ça pour de la politique,
dit-il. Des enfants et
des femmes tués chez eux.
La guerre au Liban n'a jamais
été si cruelle", croit-il.
C'est là qu'il veut maintenant
retourner. La crise y est telle
que le Liban fait naufrage.
Mais vu d'ici, il ressemble
à une bouée de sauvetage.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Lvi